l'installation de bornes de recharge de
véhicules électriques c'est l'une des
spécialités du site bouygues énergie et
services de plaisir et nous sommes avec
charles brisard bonjour bonjour vous
êtes chargé d'affaires sur cet
établissement
est-ce que vous pouvez nous le présenter
ce site alors ici vous êtes sur le
centre de plaisir
on accueille une quarantaine de
compagnons de chefs d'équipés trop de
son support dont je fais partie la
chargée d'affaires
les rh et également les contrôleurs de
gestion
on travaille principalement sur les
infrastructures extérieures donc on
parle ici de candélabres de
signalisation lumineuse tricolore est
également de bornes de recharge pour
véhicules électriques
quels sont les différents métiers qu'on
retrouve sur ce site alors ici vous avez
principalement des électriciens et des
terrassiers qui participent tous les
jours à l'illumination des villes et la
recharge des véhicules électriques par
les installations et la maintenance
alors aujourd'hui on va voir
l'installation d'une borne de recharge
des véhicules électriques dans quelques
minutes on va partir à noisy le roi
comment évolue cette activité autour de
ce type d'infrastructure alors pour nous
c'est une activité très porteuse assez
récente même si le groupe bull energy
services et l a6 impliquent depuis plus
de neuf ans maintenant
la croissance du nombre de bornes de
recharge installée est exponentielle au
même titre que celle des véhicules
électriques en france dans les yvelines
c'est une activité aussi porteuse c'est
une activité porteuse pour nous pour le
centre de plaisir principalement on en
installe actuellement une centaine sur
l'année 2019 combien de personnes
travaillent autour de ce type
d'infrastructure est ce que ce sont les
mêmes qui installe d'autres dispositifs
de d'electric de lampadaires ou d'autres
activités que vous installez alors des
compagnons qui travaillent ici ainsi que
les chefs d'equipe sont formés sur les
gestes électrique de tout type
ils sont susceptibles de travail sur
l'éclairage public également des bornes
de recharge
même si ce matériel est un petit peu
spécifique par sa programmation
on a des compagnons qui sont formés
uniquement la programmation et d'autres
qui ont des activités diverses
quelle formation ils ont suivi quels
sont les différents types de de
formation d'école qu'on peut intégrer
pour ensuite travailler chez vous alors
on accueille tout type de profil pour
l'installation des bornes des personnes
qui sont en apprentissage chez nous des
gens qui sont qui ont suivi un cursus un
peu plus long à la fois des monteurs
électriciens donc d une formation
d'électricien ou des électrotechnicien
pour la programmation par exemple vous
l'avez dire il ya une installation de
plus en plus importante de ce type de
d'outils de type d'infrastructure
comment vous adaptez aussi en terme de
main d'homme je suppose que vous
recherchez beaucoup de personnel alors
effectivement c'est des métiers nouveaux
pour nous on a des besoins assez
important aussi bien sur les bornes de
recharge mais aussi sur les smart city
en général parce que c'est des métiers
porteurs et qui nous demande beaucoup de
connaissances
on recrute pas mal de compagnons de chef
d'equipe électricien électrotechnicien
pour l'implantation ce type de matériel
quel type de profil vous recherchez
plutôt des personnes expérimentées ou
des jeunes qui sortent d'écoles on
cherche plutôt des jeunes effectivement
parce que pour des sujets d'appétence
pour les sujets électronique et de
programmation d'informatique
on a on a plus de facilité à former ce
type de personnes sur les métiers des
infrastructures de recharge bon c'est le
moment on va aller sur le chantier allez
on y va et nous voilà sur le chantier
avec julien ardouin et sébastien mulard
de techniciens de bouygues énergie et
services ils sont actuellement en train
de poser une borne de recharge de
véhicules électriques on va voir comment
ça se passe tout de suite
[Musique]
je viens voir bonjour bonjour vous avez
32 ans vous ça fait dix ans que vous
travaillez pour bouygues énergie et
services
qu'est-ce que vous êtes actuellement en
train de faire on est en train de poser
une bande d'une borne de recharge
électrique pour les véhicules
électriques
donc on est en train de mettre quatre
tiges quatre tiges à frapper dans un
béton qui a déjà été qui a déjà été fait
par le par un autre service pour la
cellule au sol c'est une activité de
plus en plus fréquentes dans votre
quotidien
depuis une petite année oui sur l'
agence de plaisir on en pose de plus en
plus quelle formation vous avez fait
pour faire ce métier j'ai fait un bep
électrotechnique sur versailles et un
bac pro sur montmorillon à côté de
poitiers
vu que c'est une activité de plus en
plus croissante c'est un secteur qui
embauche et vous avez aussi je suppose
des personnes en apprentissage les
personnes que vous formez aussi la
bouille énergie et services
oui je suis moniteur dans la société
d'un jeune en apprentis et du coup la
société oui embauche pour la cause des
bornes et aussi pour d'autres pour
d'autres activités au sein de la société
qu'est ce qui vous reste à faire là
maintenant la mise à niveau de la borne
et puis après raccorder la mise à la
terre de la bande et puis après il sera
opérationnel les personnes pourront
venir sans dans un deuxième temps est né
dix viendra la mettre sous tension et
au préalable la bande a été programmé
pour que
au sein de la supervision derrière la
cuisse est lui sur internet et qui
puisse la gérer entre guillemets je
garderai merci beaucoup et justement la
partie programmation la partie
supervision on y va tout de suite sur
saint quentin en yvelines dans
l'immeuble future a3
il
[Musique]
aujourd'hui on opère 5254 points de
charge ce qui fait plus de 2300 aux
bornes ce qu'une borne souvent il ya
deux points de charge
actuellement il ya 200 sessions de
recharge en cours et que dans la journée
il y avait eu six ans il existe deux
centres d'exploitation bouygues énergie
et services en france à toulouse et à
montigny le bretonneux ses
collaborateurs s'occupe des relations
avec les fournisseurs et des services
après l'installation de la borne
on a des missions extrêmement varié
entre régler des problèmes de borne donc
réglé dès l'époque de bornes régler des
soucis avec le la supervision assuré que
le paiement des sessions de charges se
fasse bien répondre à des interrogations
clients il ya des niveaux ingénieurs
autour d'eux parce qu'il faut vraiment
connaître la bande de recharge
comprendre ce qu'elle nous dit concevoir
tout le système informatique
les nouveaux modèles de bornes sont
testés dans ce laboratoire c'est le cas
de la city charge un système conçu par
bouygues énergie et services déployés
sur les lampadaires publics
ce petit boîtier vous voyez en fait
simule un simulateur de véhicules
électriques si je fais le test sur cette
bande
je passe un badge donc laborde
m'identifie elle m'autoriserai la porte
je branche mon véhicule électrique
et ensuite donc j'ai appuyé sur ce petit
bouton pour dire que le vide pour
simuler le dialogue du véhicule avec la
borne et maintenant je vais lancer la
charge pour utiliser ses infrastructures
l'usager se rend sur une application
pour identifier les bornes les plus
proches accro nerfs on opère également d
des bornes de recharge publiques et à
deux bornes
effectivement quelques points de
recharge donc si je vais dessus vous
cliquer sur la carte je vois l'adresse
et je vois également du coup sûr quelle
prise je peux me recharger qu'elle
puisse en jeu peu moins chargé nous
suivons les activités de développement
des ventes de voitures électriques donc
c'est un marché naissant
on espère que l'arrivée de 50 nouveaux
référence à l'année prochaine va
accélérer fortement ce marché qui ont
aujourd'hui à une croissance d'à peu
près 30% par an et qui devrait atteindre
50 à 60 % de croissance où les ans dans
les prochaines années
avec cette augmentation exponentielle du
marché bouygues énergie et services
recherche de nouveaux collaborateurs
pour cette filière